Los sinsontes son unos bichos muy listos.
(Risas)
De verdad que lo son.
Los sinsontes -- Mimus polyglottos --
son los maestros de ceremonia del reino animal.
Ellos escuchan, imitan y remezclan todo lo que les gusta.
Se montan su sinfonía en mi ventana todas las mañanas.
Los escucho cantando los sonidos de las alarmas de los coches
como si fueran canciones de primavera.
O sea, que lo que tú puedas decir, un sinsonte puede imitarlo con un graznido.
Así que atentos, voy a cazar sinsontes.
Los atraparé a lo largo de todo el país
y los meteré en frascos de conserva como cócteles Molotov de sinsonte.
(Risas)
Sí... Y conforme vaya circulando por algún barrio,
veréis, donde la gente tiene un montón, cogeré uno de los sinsontes que atrapé
en otro barrio donde no había ninguno y lo soltaré, ya sabéis.
Allá va el pajarito, ahí van sus palabras, "Juanito, Juanito,
vente a comer, mi hijo!"
Oh, voy a convertirme en el Johnny Appleseed del sonido.
(Risas)
Cruzando calles de ciudades al azar, vacilando con un Cadillac descapotable
con un gran asiento trasero, llevando como 13 bolsas de papel marrón de Walmart
llenas de sinsontes cargados, y conseguiré a todo el mundo.
(Risas)
Pillaré al tonto de las noticias diciendo:
"Volvemos enseguida con más noticias sobre la crisis".
Pillaré a algún imbécil en un bareto preguntando de qué marca es el hielo.
Pillaré a la señora de la lavandería que parece saber siempre lo que es bueno.
Pillaré a tu cartero haciendo planes para la cena.
Te pillaré en la última mentira que dijiste.
Conseguiré ese "Cariño, dame la jodida guía de la tele".
Pillaré una solitaria y breve frase con un auténtico error:
"Sí, supongo que podría entrar, pero solo por un minuto".
(Risas)
Tomaré una clase de inglés en Chinatown y aprenderé: "Está lloviendo, está diluviando".
Pondré un sinsonte en un tren nocturno para pillar a un viejo roncando.
Copiaré a tu ex-amante diciéndole a otro: "Buenos días".
Grabaré todos los "buenos días".
Me da igual cómo los digas.
Aloha. Konichiwa. Shalom. Ah-Salam Alaikum.
Todas dicen lo mismo.
Y quizás construya una jaula dorada.
Cubriré el fondo con las páginas de un viejo cuaderno.
Dentro meteré a un sinsonte para
dar breves explicaciones, padres hippies.
(Risas)
¿Qué tiene que ver un violín con la tecnología?
¿Hacia dónde se dirige el mundo?
En un extremo, barras doradas --
en el otro, un planeta entero.
Estamos a 12 billones de años luz del borde.
Es una conjetura.
El espacio es longitud y anchura que continúan indefinidamente,
pero no puedes comprar un billete para un viaje comercial al espacio en América,
porque los países están empezando a comer como nosotros, vivir como nosotros y morir como nosotros.
Podrías querer apartar la mirada, porque
es un tritón a punto de regenerar su cola,
y dar la mano propaga más gérmenes que besarse.
Hay alrededor de 10 millones de bacteriófagos por trabajo.
Es un mundo realmente extraño dentro de un nanotubo.
Las mujeres pueden hablar, los negros conspirar, los blancos construir edificios robustos,
nosotros construimos robustos soles.
La superficie de la Tierra está completamente llena de agujeros,
y aquí estamos nosotros, justo en medio.
(Risas)
Es la voz de la vida la que nos llama para venir y aprender.
Cuando todos los pequeños sinsontes vuelen libres,
sonarán como los últimos cuatro días.
Subiré a los gurús, bajaré a los profesores,
artistas y comerciantes desfasados, predicadores filipinos, sopladores de hojas,
barmans, cirujanos plásticos, hooligans, basureros,
tus diputados locales en el punto de mira, tipos en helicópteros sobrevolando,
Todos son oídos.
Todo el mundo tiene a este sincero sinsonte de testigo.
Y yo estoy en ello.
Estoy en esto hasta que todo se difunda,
con salas de chat e imitaciones y puede que mamás acostando a los niños
cantando: "Duérmete niño, no digas nada,
espera al señor del sinsonte".
(Risas)
Sí. Y luego vienen los equipos de noticias,
y las entrevistas callejeras, las cartas al editor.
Todo el mundo preguntado, quién es el responsable de esta
cacofonía de sinsontes por toda la ciudad, por todo el país, y alguien al final
avisará al Ayuntamiento de Monterrey, California y llegará hasta mí,
y me ofrecerán la llave de la ciudad.
Una enorme llave de la ciudad bañada en oro
y eso es todo lo que necesito, porque si la consigo, puedo abrir con ella el aire.
Escucharé lo que falta, y lo pondré allí.
Gracias, TED.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: "Guau".
¡Guau!
(Aplausos)